はいみなさんこんにちは道元です
50万人突破しましたありがとうござい
ますいや本当に皆さんのおかげだと思って
いますありがとうございますそして今後
ともよろしくお願いしますでこれを機に
ですねちょっとした
発表をしたいと思っていますで
僕の
視聴者であれば
わかると思うんですけどこのチャンネルで
は日本語上手
上手っていう言葉が
ミームになっていますそして多くの冗談の
オチになっています
ですので
結構前からですねいろんな視聴者から
いわゆる
ジョーズグッズはいつ出しますかって
ずっと前から聞かれていますで僕も作り
たいなとずっと思っていたんですけど
どうせ作るのであれば
ごめんなさいねあの声が
風邪ひいてるんで
声がちょっとおかしいんですけどどうせ
作るのであれば
面白いものを作りたいなと思っていました
しで面白いだけじゃなく面白いだけじゃ
なくて
実用的なものを作りたいなと思ってまし
たっていうのは例えばそのグッズを着れば
日本人からはもう
日本語上手って言われないそういうグッズ
を作りたいなと思ってました
なのでそうだからこそ結構そのデザインに
関してはずっと悩んでいったんですけど
最近いいデザインを思いついたので
今日それを皆さんに紹介したいと思います
結論から言いますと
印鑑のデザインにしました日本ではこう
何かを証明するときに
印鑑を使おうじゃないですかなので
上手って書いてある
印鑑が押された
グッズだったら
面白いんじゃないかなと思いましたしまあ
日本語上手って多分言われないだろうしで
さらに言うと日本の伝統的な文化も入って
いてまあそれもそれで
面白いんじゃないかなと思いましたで早速
ですけど今からそれに
新しいグッズに着替えて
皆さんに見せたいと思っています
はいじゃじゃーんこれですはいさっき言っ
たように日本人がこれを見れば
日本語上手って絶対に言わないと思います
何しろそう書いてあるしさらに言うと
でもある意味これも日本語上手って言わ
ないよな